Anyone with a blue suitcase
you may now board.
Finally.
No. Not you, sir.
Not me? This is a blue suitcase.
That's a blue computer bag.
I read on the Internet that
it's not against the law for me
to go to the bathroom while
the fasten seatbelt sign is on.
Seatbelt sign is on.
but is it against the law
though?
The light is on.
Is it against the law..
You see that there's a picture
of a seatbelt on that sign.
Oh! Holy shock-zu, massage!
Econonmy Plus!
OK. I just I just wanted
some leg room.
OK max leg room
you get yours.
Meanwhile, I'm gonna go
Hayden Panettiere
on some terries.
especially when they get froggy.
ribbit ribbit.
You have to have the cevapi,
cevapito is
what you're going to have.
Oh don't they serve that
in the cafe across the street.
NO!!!
Our soup today is a
(speaks french)
just a dash of (french)
and served with (french)
Hello Greece. Where the yogurt
flows like water.
Mm yes.
Like Gogurt but to stay.